during testimony today I don't know if  you saw this the Acting Director of  National Intelligence Joseph McGuire  said he doesn't know the identity of the  whistleblower doesn't know his identity  yeah apparently Congress is going to  reveal his identity on the mask singer  we're looking forward to that yeah which  costume is it gonna be from what I hear  he's gonna be the bumblebee bumblebee  vice president Mike Pence said that by  trying to remove Trump from office the  Democrats are trying to quote overturn  the will of the people yeah  then pence told the Democrats to keep up  the good work a Republican member of  Congress said Democrats won't be happy  until they see naked photos of President  Trump yeah  in response Melania said trust me they  won't be happy then either  you